hexal one a commencé effectivement en
1973 mais on a changé le format plaisir
fois au début on était sept parfois huit
sur scène et avec l'arrivée du zouk
il fallait réinventer exhale one et
hexagone est devenu un trio depuis
presque trente ans maintenant d'un futur
williams clavier viviane wallace à la
basse et moi même et on est un trio qui
circulent et on est accompagné par
plusieurs groupes
aujourd'hui on a un groupe dans l'océan
indien à la réunion on a un groupe en
martinique à la guadeloupe à la
dominique
aux etats unis et ont donc ça réduit des
frais mais aussi ça montre que la
musique des bâlois n'est connue pour les
musiciens du monde créole et le monde
créole et le marché creux si on ne doit
pas les commercialement n'est pas un
marché
l'église et 10 ans alors à quand un
marché de la musique réel à mon avis il
y à un marché très important de la
musique créole qui existe mais c'est pas
structuré si on doit parler de manière
quantitatif même si on doit ajouter les
consommateurs de la guyane d'haïti
sainte-lucie dominique martini
guadeloupe de l'océan indien seychelles
sierra et c est la diaspora haïtienne au
canada aux états-unis en europe ça ça
compte mais on n'est pas structurée
hommes j'ai par exemple des dix qui sont
sortis à la réunion et qui sont jamais
sortis aux antilles et vice versa donc
quand on a commencé le wall cruel music
festival
ce n'était pas uniquement festival pour
avoir trois jours de musique c'était
quelque chose qui devrait être comme le
1000 m à marcher de musique créole où
les producteurs de venir faire des
échanges des distributeurs des éditeurs
et ses hommes
ça n'a pas suivi cette route mais j'ai
toujours l'espoir qu'un jour va
consolider son match et créole et quand
un jeune martiniquais ça devrait sortir
un disque en martinique que sa laisse et
ça va sortir en guadeloupe à sainte
lucie en haïti et caetera et ça
représente des millions de consommateurs
c'est un grand
grand marché niche commandé à nice
markets